did you know that a costume from The
Wolverine Comics will finally be
utilized in Deadpool 3. thank you MCU
and that Hugh Jackman has an alternate
title to the movie that he uses with his
family Wolverine we're taking you on a
behind the scenes look at everything we
know so far about the making of 2024's
Deadpool 3. one of the biggest recent
reveals is that Hugh Jackman hi as
Wolverine is going to rock a comic
accurate suit yup that iconic fairly
ugly but still cool yellow getup that he
wears in the comic books is definitely
making an appearance in Deadpool 3. this
Revelation came courtesy of both Ryan
and Hughes Instagram they both posted
photos of the pair in their costumes
from on set hey Hugh you want to play
Wolverine one more time and then some
footage was released that showed the two
filming a fight scene and in all of
those Hugh has on a bright yellow suit
like it was ripped from the pages of the
comics oddly enough in the shots he
doesn't have on the trademark cowl that
Wolverine rocks in the comics but most
Die Hard fan fans assume that the photos
don't necessarily mean he doesn't wear
it in the movie either he wasn't wearing
the cowl in that particular moment
during the movie or Pew got hot in it
and took it off for a bit because it
seems unlikely they'd go through the
trouble of Designing a whole suit for
him but leave out that signature helmet
right why go out of your way to almost
appease all the comic book fans either
way the internet was a buzz when the
photos came out there have been a lot of
Hardcore fans who haven't quite
understood the decision to steer clear
of the yellow suit all these years I
mean other than the fact that it's
pretty hideous looking Logan's cool
leather jacket look definitely beats it
in the fashion department and let's be
honest regardless of what he wears it's
still way cool that Wolverine is in the
movie of course at this point the fact
that Hugh Jackman is in the cast of
Deadpool 3 isn't exactly huge news
anymore but it's still hella exciting to
fans of X-Men Deadpool and the adorbs
Bromance between Ryan Reynolds and Hugh
Jackman they just need a celebrity
Bromance name huyan Rue okay those need
work either way the two have long been
known to joke around with each other
playfully suggesting that they're
actually enemies Ryan seems to be
continuing with this transparent farce
even when talking about Deadpool 3 when
asked by Jimmy Fallon why he wanted to
work with Hugh Jackman Ryan started
waxing poetic about his career and the
choices he's fortunate enough to make he
said that he feels incredibly lucky that
he gets to work in the entertainment
industry and that he'd gotten to be in
it for so long and as such he's at a
point where he can be selective about
who he works with but I am excited
because I'm A Logan fan so but of course
Hugh likes to Dish it back he put out a
video in early 2023 talking about how
much he liked Ryan's movie spirited but
he also noted that at the time the song
Good afternoon featuring a performance
by Reynolds was on the short list for a
potential Oscar nomination for best song
with his tongue firmly planted in his
cheek he begged Oscar voters not to
include the song in their list of
nominees his reasoning Ryan Reynolds
getting nomination it'd be a problem
when they weren't messing with each
other online and on TV the two did have
a movie to make which makes us all
Wonder well what's it gonna be about
Reynolds and crew haven't revealed much
about the plot of the movie other than
the fact that Ryan called it a
multiversal road trip with Wolverine oh
and the fact that Deadpool 3 sees both
characters officially entering into the
MCU that's a big deal because it means
there's potential for a lot more
Crossover with characters from the MCU
and plot lines and the like and given
the fact that like the previous Deadpool
movies Deadpool will be R-rated it means
it'll be the first R-rated movie in the
MCU and since the Multiverse is involved
it seems like there might also be some
potential time traveling involved too
that is evidenced more by leaked photos
of a shot from the set where you can
clearly see a giant 20th Century Fox
sign and for those of you scoring at
home we're not in the 20th century
anymore at one point I actually thought
for like half a second that Ryan and
Hugh were about to give everyone some
multiversal road trip spoilers not to
mention how they're working Wolverine
into the movie since that's another of
the biggest mysteries of Deadpool he's
known to have died in the movie Logan
Ryan and Hugh ever the pranksters put
out a tongue-in-cheek video where they
pretended to do a rambling speech full
of spoilers but they were drowned out by
the sounds of whams wake me up before
you go go over their dialogue it was
another of the Duo's pranktastic and
hilarious moments in their movie star
Bromance and they totally got me but it
didn't actually answer any of our
questions about when the movie takes
place but there have been some
occasional BTS Clues at the very least
we know what happens before 2029 which
is when the movie Logan took place
that's courtesy of Wolverine himself the
story is pretty so we pray that in the
storyline and Ryan talked about how they
did all the necessary storyline and
character work to make sure that
Deadpool 3 didn't mess with the
established story that we've seen with
Logan and the X-Men Universe we've
figured out a way to do it we wouldn't
mess with that and when you combine the
previously mentioned 20th Century Fox
sign it seems like the timeline here
might just be in the past the future and
in some other multiverses regardless of
when the plot takes place it wouldn't
have happened without Hugh Jackman
deciding to jump back into his famous
character so why did Hugh decide to
return well since he can't say for the
payday duh you had to come up with other
reasons why he decided to return to play
Wolverine he says that his wife had
asked him what he wanted to do next and
he wasn't sure but then lamb like a bolt
of lightning he suddenly had a vision I
know it's just driving down a day later
and I thought and it came to me like
that and beyond having a sudden
Spiritual Awakening Hugh admitted that
the thought of him and Ryan battling it
out together on the screen got him super
excited after all Su points out those
two characters have a pretty fun and
gritty dynamic because when I keep
thinking of me and Ryan of Deadpool and
Wolverine there's also a dynamic that
I've never really got to do before is
Wolverine so despite the the fact that
he's going to be playing this character
for the 10th time he's psyched that
there will be elements to the acting and
filming process that he's never been
able to do over the years of course Hugh
being Q he also had to put a cheeky spin
on the movie title when asked about
appearing as Wolverine for the 10th time
in Deadpool 3. Hugh had a decidedly
different way of labeling it I mean you
categorize it as the Deadpool movie we
like to call it Wolverine Tim in that
same convo interviewer Chris Wallace
delicately pointed out to Hugh that
perhaps it would be more of a challenge
to get back into Peak Physical shape now
that he's in his mid-50s as opposed to
when he was 32. he agreed though he
admitted to being a lot more Zen about
the whole thing he told Wallace that
after years of getting into Wolverine
shape he's learned that the biggest
thing for him is that it takes a lot of
time AKA he can't try to rush it or get
mad at himself if it's not happening
overnight but fortunately after he
finished a run on Broadway in The Music
Man he left himself a nice chunk of time
to work with his trainer and get back
into the the physical form he needed to
be in for the character so we have six
months from when I finished to when I
start filming that's going to be my job
for six months and in fact he mentioned
that performing in a Musical on Broadway
gets you into pretty great shape to
begin with I'm really fit right now so
at least he was starting from a solid
place when he needed to get back into
Wolverine's shape speaking of pretty
solid there's the hashtag couple goals
of the solid relationship between Ryan
and his lovely wife Blake Lively and
even when Ryan is off working it appears
Blake is down for a visit to set and
there were photos leaked of Blake and
their three daughters visiting Ryan
Reynolds while they shot but while it
was exciting to think of the possibility
of the Reynolds Lively Clan all being in
Deadpool 3. it appears that at least on
that day of shooting it was a family
visit and not a work day for Blake and
the girls one actress who is returning
to set and not just for a visit is
Jennifer Garner it's been confirmed
she's a part of Deadpool 3 as Elektra
while we don't know yet many details
about her appearance it's an exciting
prospect effect mostly because it likely
confirms the multiversal aspects of the
movie okay now that I have fully ramped
up everyone's excitement over Deadpool 3
we just have to wait a little longer
until late 2024. what does anyone have a
time machine I can use to quickly see it
I swear I'll just pop to late 2024 and
right back after the movie well either
way have any thoughts about Deadpool 3